GTA 6 what about
that yeah Alena thought she six right
yeah yeah alen thought she had a
husband no this is that mean your child
thought he had a father
yep sorry bud not for a couple months
hey man you're going to have to cry that
one
out when is this come out um no no no no
2025 or year next year next year but
like next November probably yeah yeah
sorry bud your first Christmas is going
to be
rough hey man if you're if you're
thirsty there's there's water go ahead
he's going to have a lonely first
Christmas your dad's busy yeah your dad
has to go away now close the door just
never come
out I liked the trailer a lot I watched
it this morning and I was like [__]
fire me up yeah go yeah isn't that crazy
look at this 78 78 yeah this morning
when I watched it it was like 65 so just
in the drive here it got 10 million more
views this is the last this is the last
cultural thing ever yeah that'll ever
happen yep yeah it's the last one yeah
there is nothing left so enjoy it yep
it's going to be fun in this literally
after Grand Theft Auto 6 we can finish
the game and then we can all
suicide cuz there will be nothing left
how did you pronounce that suicide
suicide yeah suicide yeah
suicide yeah this is it this is the last
thing everyone knows it too that's why
there's so many views mhm I've been
playing CS still I I gave back in I'm
back on my addiction okay
um so I play a game dude on my team his
name is Ronald
McDonald he's not a nice guy
okay
toxic you might say racist not racist
just kind of an [__] okay you know
like there's one guy on our team he's
like this classic he's like the classic
like Counter-Strike low rank Stoner mhm
like the way they talk is oh [__] man I
shouldn't have Peak they every sentence
is in that tone and so he says something
to that nature he goes [__] my bad
dude I flashed him at least I thought
the Ronald McDonald goes I [__] hate
you you're
muted which is funny okay but then uh we
like we lost the second round and he
goes GG boys this game's over it was
like kind of just rude and demotivated
and he was like bottom fragging the
whole time okay and so get B Attitude
yeah bad attitude all so I get I get
into the next game and Ronald is on the
opposite team so I tell my team I go yo
that dude seems pretty tilted if we just
focus killing him and getting under his
skin I think he'll throw and it'll we'll
just inevitably turn it into a 4v5 and
we'll win but so so I just say I think
he's tilted like in unison I just
happened to queue with four guys who all
sound the same as well okay and they're
like thank God they're like good
news they're like how tilted like how
tilt they're like asking questions so
then so what does that mean if someone's
tilted yeah he's pissed he's raging yeah
so what does it mean to throw so some
guys in Counterstrike they get so mad
that they just throw they don't like
play with the team they'll just go die
on purpose it's like they hate
themselves in the game yeah and so I've
done that before yeah yeah so uh ranking
up in Counter-Strike is sometimes pretty
annoying so you want to get as many wins
or you want to get wins when you can so
uh from round
one so the games are like 24 rounds the
whole every round we win they just keep
hitting him with puns okay or if they
like the whole time we're playing
they're like where's Ronald like like we
could be losing around like as long as
we get Ronald like we're still on goal
that's so good this one guy on my team
it was so [__] up but every time he
addressed him it was always like hey
[__] face hey MC [__] hey Ronald MCD
dumbass like it was just
every and I he can hear this no like te
that's what made it funny is they're
typing it to him oh okay yeah he never
muted anyone and he just kept responding
so then I said guys he's in a bad place
like he's just taking it it's like five
guys being like how was that Grimace
purple [__] in your ass he's like pretty
good he just cut to him in his office
yeah like I [__] suck
man I'm
trash I do take Grim's
[__] I suck on that [__] all day oh my
God man I was like all five of us were
just weeping except the one kid that
kept who didn't have anything clever to
say they just kept cussing at him that
kid voice [__] face that kid's voice was
like I'm finding Ronald I just killed
Ronald just that would suck so bad to
have a whole team just targeting you I
know I've never I haven't seen that in a
minute on Counter Strike but I haven't
like typically when that happens it's
like mean-spirited like it's not clever
but the fact that all of them just kept
trying to come up with
puns the one kid was on fire and this
other kid goes man is this a standup
comedy night or something man you're
killing it
[Laughter]
dude yeah I was weeping man I do love
that sort of like specific gamer rage
where you're just like destructive
against yourself like cool [__] if I'm
just going to [__] die I just run out
here and die again okay run out and die
again cool I don't know why I [__]
why do I even [__] spawn if I die
cool yeah man I think we put him in that
place Place yeah took him to a dark ass
place
man would be it would be a great scene
if like we're all just laughing on the
other side and cut to his keyboard and
his just blood all over the
keyboard Jesus side of his head all over
his posters why did I laugh so hard at
that CU it's a good punchline I was
picturing that gift for the dude
bang he roll mcfuck it good
game you go what a loser he's probably
sucking off Grimace right now oh that's
dark blur that blur that blur my hand
but you get the
implication anyway oh I didn't realize
that this reindeer here is like oh yeah
banded up I know yeah that was that was
a nice touch Luke that was smart yeah
very nice touch nice
touch oh did you dude check this out
this has like a crazy
feature
God damn
[Laughter]
dude God damn throat go back
here
jeez I broke it talking about making the
yulti
gay oh [__] I broke it you definitely
broke it
dude the two-handed
[Laughter]
grip oh [__] ow my face
hurts
oh